yo what up everybody hope you're
enjoying your holiday as much as I am
family time but wanted to set up this
next keynote did this at the Nordic
forum a lot of new topics went pretty
deep with a bunch of people hope you
enjoy it and see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Finland I'm super excited to be here and
really very honestly I'd like to get to
the Q&A portion of this pretty quickly I
wrote a book called askgaryvee because I
do believe that these kind of events are
incredible and and a lot of very smart
and and special people come and
pontificate and what-have-you but the
interaction is the single greatest way
to get deep instead of wide and I think
at the end of day for everybody that has
decided to come to this conference
there's tangible things we want there's
something we want and that's actually
where I want to start actually you know
what let's start with this before I go
into this by show of hands how many
people here have no idea who I am or
anything about my spiel tell the truth
raise them that [ __ ] hurts
thank you feeling I'll see you next time
that's tough way to start I thought that
was the case and I understand why and so
I'm gonna spend a few minutes giving you
my background because I think it's the
foundation of what I want to bring here
I did a lot of work on the flight over
here to understand the audience I think
a lot of times when I speak at
conferences or other speakers speak we
make some Mis distinctions of b2b b2c
things of that nature and so
understanding the makeup of a lot of
people in this audience and
understanding the landscape of the
social media grid the digital grid I'm
gonna try to factor my talk very
aggressively towards a little bit more
of a b2b environment it's interesting as
a marketer than a business person so
many people think when they think about
social media it's so much more in a b2c
environment yet GE which is one of our
largest clients of my firm vaynermedia
is easily the happiest client we have
because at the end of the day before I
give you my background I want to set
this up immediately which is the
following no matter what you do in this
room no matter what business you come
from no matter what position you hold
within that organization whether you're
a solo entrepreneur or work at a big
organization there's only one thing that
bounds us all together in this room the
number one thing from a business
perspective that ties all of us together
in this room is quite simple at the end
of the day before you tell me how great
your SAS product is or your service or
how delicious your wine is or how great
you are if you're building your brand no
matter what before you get a chance to
tell me how great you are or it is or
that is you need somebody's attention
the number one thing that everybody here
is battling on the currency of business
forever and everything by the way is
attention and the biggest thing that
everybody in this room is being affected
and this is worldwide whether I'm in
Asia South America the US obviously the
you know apps are slightly different the
usage is different but the one thing
that is common the one thing that I
absolutely want to spend the majority of
my time on is if you were sitting in
this room
you do not understand the slide that I
have up there that says I day trade
attention and build businesses you are
very vulnerable in the speed of which
the market is changing if you do not
understand that if you are religious or
emotional of where you send your message
whether that is print or radio or
television or conferences or Direct Mail
or Facebook Twitter snapchat or tumblr
if you are emotional if you draw lines
in the sand if you talk about how you
used to do it or how your grandfather
built the business or what is
tried-and-true
in a 20-17 world you were massively
vulnerable the speed in which our
consumers whether in a b2b or b2c
environment are switching and moving has
never been faster and listen I stand in
front of you I know Dick Costolo here
the former CEO of Twitter I saw him
backstage when a very good friend of
mine my break out in the States was
Twitter I was one of the first movers on
that platform I amassed a million
followers on Twitter I would wish and
want that Twitter was still the number
one place that everybody spent all their
time on I was on the top of the heap but
as it started getting competition from
Instagram and snapchat and other
platforms and as the attention was not
as deeply in that platform it hurt my
feelings I wasn't excited that I spent
all of 2007 through 2010 eight [ __ ]
hours a day replying to people of what
wine goes with fish every day eight
hours a day to build a base I wasn't
excited that people were moving away
from it I just knew that I had no choice
that that was the punchline that as much
as you'd like it to be the way that it
most benefits you the end consumer does
other stuff and so that's basically been
the story of my life my life starts in
being born in Belarus and a former
Soviet Union I came to the US when I was
three years old we were very very very
poor I live in a studio apartment with
eight family members a third of the size
of the stage that I'm on
and my dad and my mom as you could
imagine are very much my heroes my dad
worked every hour of his life being a
stock boy in a liquor store
you know actually how many people in
this room are immigrants or children of
immigrants please raise your hand just
curious so for the hands that are in
this room they know something that I
know which is immigrants have an amazing
advantage they have a very tried and
true strategy that we could all learn
from what immigrants are very good at
doing is when they come to a new country
they work and they don't spend any money
on dumb [ __ ] for ten years and so that's
what my parents did and and eventually
my dad was able to buy a small liquor
store in New Jersey I was a very
entrepreneurial kid I was day trading
attention from a young age I had six
lemonade stands when I was seven years
old and I would spend all my time trying
to figure out what tree and what pole to
put the signs on because I was watching
people drive and trying to figure out
what signs this I was a very sick child
when I was 12 and 13 I was selling
baseball cards which were very popular
in the United States at the time and I
was making one to two thousand dollars a
weekend selling them in the malls
of New Jersey which was great and I was
rich for a young kid and it was
fantastic but then my career changed my
dad dragged me into the liquor store and
I hated it at first but luckily I
realized that people collected wine I
was into collecting sports memorabilia
that was my passion that was the
connection and I decided that I was
going to jump into my family business
open up 4,000 liquor stores across
America sell the franchise one day and
buy the New York Jets American football
team because that is my dream you to
stand up you to stand up let's clap it
up for these guys
[Applause]
in 1994 I was in my dorm room in college
my friend came over to me and I want to
start wrapping this up and getting it to
what matters to you he brought me into a
room it was the first time I heard cool
couch which was the Internet I was very
excited about it I didn't know what it
was I said something stupid like is this
the information superhighway I looked at
it this is you know there's a lot of
youngsters in here this was 1994 I
literally stood there and watched people
on the internet for five hours it was
that crazy it's it was just that insane
it was so new and when I finally had my
turn to go on there when I finally had
my turn to go on there within 20 minutes
I landed on a message board where people
are creating and buying and cards
baseball cards and I realized my god I
can do business on this thing and over
the next year I went headfirst and
learned about eBay learned about what
was going on in Amazon started learning
the early internet culture and in 1996 I
launched winelibrary.com one of the
first to e-commerce wine businesses in
America from 1998 to 2003 in a five year
window I grew my dad's business from a
three to a sixty million dollar business
on very very important terms that
matters to this entire room I had no
money it was a three million dollar
business that had 10% gross profit
$300,000 before expenses there's no
marketing budget what I needed is to
make every penny work like a dollar
so the strategy became day-trading
attention when you day trade attention
my friends here's what you do you don't
overspend on what everybody believes is
tried-and-true every single company in
this gorgeous conference right now is
grossly over spending money on things
that they've been doing for the last
decade because it's the things that they
accept or the reporting justifies it or
they're just lazy to try something new
everyone everyone and so what you do
when you day trade attention is you have
to find angles what's underpriced how
many people here do email marketing or
have done email marketing in their lives
raise your hands perfect a lot of you in
1997
I started an email newsletter most
people that came into my liquor store
didn't even know what email was in 1997
I collected I collected I collected in a
1998 I had a two hundred thousand person
email newsletter with ninety one percent
open rates now it's not because I was a
genius and I know a lot of you sit here
just like I do with emails that are
thirteen to twenty three percent open
rates today it's that in 1997
nobody was emailing we hadn't ruined it
yet
one thing I promise you more than I know
that the Sun will come up tomorrow I
know that marketers ruin everything we
ruined the internet I'm trying to ruin
snapchat and musically right now we ruin
[ __ ] it's what we do so it was 91% open
rates there then Google AdWords came out
I bought the word wine on Google AdWords
for five cents a click and owned it for
nine months before anybody bid me up
because people were still on Yahoo and
asked Jeeves and other [ __ ] like that
and so that became the rinse and repeat
as I think about b2b players in this
environment it is stunning to me how
many b2b businesses here do not
understand that producing articles on
medium.com on LinkedIn
writing full content on Facebook in your
feed and then spending a hundred dollars
in ads against employees of the company
that you're trying to reach let me say
that three more times because the one
thing I promised myself as I boarded
last night in New York to get here is
I'm gonna give my talk but I'm gonna
give every single person in this
audience one thing to take home do and
then email and say thank you so let me
say it really slow right now on this day
October 6th right is that right October
6 2016 the number one deal if you day
trade attention like I do in this market
is Facebook Ads they are under priced
they are under priced because a lot of
people in this room still debate what
the ROI is or even worse they're
emotional that Facebook organic Reach
has come down
and now they have to pay for it while
you're emotional and sad that you don't
reach as many things the best ad product
that I've seen since Google AdWords has
emerged or even worse than both of those
two scenarios you haven't even done it
yet you've decided for your business
your customer is not on that platform
yet you've never spent a dollar testing
it to know if that's true or not you've
read a headline you had a friend tell
you but you actually don't do it and
you're not sure we live in a world right
now of headline readers everybody here
has a lot of opinions about Facebook and
snapchat and Instagram and influence or
LinkedIn medium but there's very few
practitioners there's very few people
that have actually placed the ads there
are very few people that understand that
the creative is the variable when you
place an ad and just cuz you did it once
doesn't mean that it doesn't work it
might mean that the creative the video
and the picture that you put out just
sucked and so as I go through all the
other things just in the middle here for
a few minutes I just want to tell you
exactly what I know what I know is I'm
involved with 15 different b2b
businesses right now GE is a client AT&T
is a client but many startups that I
invest in because I aural I also in my
mid-2000s started investing in Twitter
Facebook Tumblr uber I've done very well
in that world I basically just told you
that to brag that had no information
value but but what I know about these
b2b businesses is right now every single
person here can write an article about
their expertise in the business that
they're in not a propaganda for your SAS
product or service but an article that
would be valuable to the people that
you're trying to reach you can write
this article literally in a Facebook
post literally in a Facebook post and
then you can go to the ad product and
you can actually target employees of one
of the ways you can target on Facebook
is the employees of an organization how
many people here are in b2b raise your
hand higher know
hi for me Helsinki hire again show me
again I need to look hi perfect a
shitload a lot of you all of you all of
you need to hear this this is the
remarkable era of underpriced
opportunity in digital and social
marketing yet I'm empathetic to why most
of you do not believe that I get it
most of the advice most of the
conference's most of the articles
position this in a b2c environment I
know for example the following that if I
was to buy one of your companies the
number one thing I would do is the
following every one of you are in an
industry where there is a b2b magazine
that is the number one thing that the
people in your market read if you were a
company trying to reach customers I
would become that magazine let me
explain the other religious point of
view that this room needs to take away
from this talk this weekend
or at some point you will believe this
is true whether it is today or 12 or 24
months from now thirty six months from
now is the following
the quicker everybody in this room
understands that they are a media
company comma software company comma
wine retailer comma lawyer comma account
service provider the quicker
everybody in this room understands that
they are a media company comma those
things
the quicker you will be successful I
will tell you why you told me that
earlier they said the ad was dead you
said the ad is got to be creative and
good give it to the creatives I believe
more in your world and I'll just add to
it
the ad has to bring value the number one
thing that is happening in society in
every part of the world is the following
we as human beings no matter where we're
from we value health we want to stay
alive and the people money you like
money but the number one emerging thing
in society in value is time time is
exploding in value to us because we all
now live in a 24/7 365 world some of the
old-timers in this room
remember when the workday ended and it
just ended it wasn't getting emails at
night people expecting you to reply we
now live in a 24/7 world as a matter of
fact one of the great mistakes of my
investing career is Travis calculate the
CEO of uber was a very great friend of
mine
I passed on investing in uber in the
angel round twice i cost myself hundreds
of millions of dollars I'm very upset
about it but I invested a little bit
later on
not because Luber was doing so well but
because I realized when he came to New
York and my brother AJ took the first
uber ride oh my god
uber doesn't sell transportation uber
sells time we don't care about privacy
we care about time this is who we are as
humans and what advertising is doing in
the last 50 years is it stopping you
from doing what you want to do and it's
selling you something which means by
nature it is stealing your time which is
why the second you decide that you're a
media company and you actually want to
bring people value instead of selling
them something you win if you run home
now and misunderstood what I said which
is why I'm creating clarity right now
for you if you leave here and
misunderstood what I said you will go
home you will make a Facebook post and
you will write a propaganda or sales
post and you will push it and it will
not be successful if you heard me loud
and clear and understand who you're
trying to reach and you write an article
about something that brings them value
you will win for example a small
business in the United States that heard
this talk three years ago from me
started writing content about golf they
were a law firm but what they understood
was the people they were trying to reach
or into golf and they started writing
content about golf and use that content
as a gateway drug to close the clients
because people don't want to read your
sales pitch they don't have time people
want to read something that brings value
and the interesting thing about so many
of you in the b2b environment is you're
actually an expert or knowledgeable
about you
craft you actually know and so putting
that content to work is massively
important it was super important for me
six seven years ago that was nothing
compared to the ability of going and now
targeting the employees of the
organization that you're trying to reach
for example if you're trying to reach
the CTO or the CIO or if you actually
know the title of the person you're
trying to reach you were able to make a
video on Facebook that shows the value
prop of your product you were able to
then in the copy say does your CIO know
you were able to then run a hundred
dollars worth of ads against the
employees of that organization and then
twenty people from that organization are
gonna take that post and forward it to
the CIO the CTO the head of finance or
whoever you're trying to reach my
friends I've spent the last seven
minutes here on this rant and I
understand it's very tactical and it's
not motivational and funny but I [ __ ]
promise you that if you really
understand what I'm talking about
you will do what you actually care to do
which is sell [ __ ] right we're running
businesses here so please please
understand that because once you
understand what I just spend my time on
how that works
you'll start understanding why every
company here needs to hire an
editor-in-chief an editor in chief for
your SAS business your law firm an
editor in chief it's crazy it's not
something any of you would think and I
understand why but you have to
understand the playing field is changing
and it's changing fast in America I run
vaynermedia we are an 800 person firm
one hundred million dollars in revenue
in four years from zero basically we
work with GE and Pepsi and Under Armour
and Toyota and the biggest brands in the
world and in the u.s. my clients spend
tens of billions of dollars trying to
sell stuff here's how they do it by show
of hands in this room how many of you
now watch television not one the show
airs but on TiVo that Netflix DVR or
Amazon Prime whatever you have here on
your time
raise your hands Oh interesting
everybody everybody and I think we can
agree this is not thirteen-year-old
girls everywhere right everybody and how
many of you went given the chance
fast-forward every single commercial if
you have the option to fast-forward it's
miraculous everybody yet every company
that is trying to reach and sell you
something here in the finland market is
spending millions of dollars making
30-second videos to put in between these
shows to sell you something and even if
miraculously that video is put in front
of you because you dropped your remote
control off the bed even if that
miraculous thing happens the second a
commercial comes every person in this
room grabs this and you look at this and
you check on work or you tweet about
what you just saw or you want to see
what other people said about what she
was wearing but I promise you one thing
your attention your attention is not on
that video you can sit with me for the
next 30 years of your life and show me
every report you have your modeling mix
your data reports your big data your
surveys you can show me all your report
but my friends it is time for the people
in this room and especially the
entrepreneurs in this room to start
deploying common sense against this
reality in America the number one thing
that my clients spend money on is
programmatic banner ad buying write
banner ads across the whole web there's
nobody in this room that is looking at a
banner ad nobody's going to a website
scrolling down to the bottom left-hand
corner
and carefully consuming a banner it's
true
it's true and you clap and you clap my
friends cuz you know yet
many sell it many buy it because that's
what humans do you do what's best for
you in the short term without
understanding the long term implications
we are living through a revolution this
my friends this is the television and
the television is the radio and it's
1960 and there's a huge opportunity for
everybody in this room and you can sit
and give excuses when I and dick and
Peter come up and say ah but here in
Finland it's different you can say that
you're more than welcome but the reason
you laughed and clapped is cuz you know
it's not I know it's not cuz I look at
the data I'm not emotional about it I
don't care how reserved you are I don't
care how over-the-top I am this is just
data you're consumers are living on this
device and when you sit and make another
excuse yes Gary you're very interesting
you're very interesting speaker this is
good but my customer is not on it
they're older you're older
you're on it and so I had a very big
advantage going into marketing unlike
many people and it's why I love speaker
tomorrow Seth Godin who I enjoy so much
I'm sure you will he actually built a
business before he became a marketing
expert I built businesses and sell stuff
before I started a marketing firm my big
advantage is Mike KPI my ROI is not
headlines an adage it's not to win a
award in the South of France
my KPI and ROI is to sell something
that's what businesses do and so I
implore all of you to take a hard look
because here's the punchline and I'm
sure I didn't get to see what Peter said
but I sure know how he rolls if you
think about what has happened in our
society over the last ten years and this
is worldwide if you understand what's
gonna happen over the next ten years it
is remarkable as an effect this is
actually a very good question how many
people here are retiring in the next ten
years and I don't mean before you raise
your hand I don't mean you're gonna
crush it and make lots of money and
retire on an island I mean you're old
and you're finished raise your hand if
you're retiring in the next ten years
one two three four five okay so for the
nine of you
you could take some of what I've said
with a grain of salt right but for the
rest of you please understand if you are
not a practitioner whether you are the
CEO the head of sales or entry-level
Yorker if you don't understand how this
stuff works if you've not signed up for
Instagram and snapchat this is not a
waste of your time think of it this way
we are running a marathon and if you
don't start getting on the treadmill and
getting ready for the marathon when the
marathon comes you will not be able to
run you understand
so downloading these things and
understanding these things is not for
fun or being cool it's gonna be the only
game what do you think is happening here
there are 60 year old men in here who
sent the poop emoji in the last 24 hours
we are changing the way we communicate
there are people in this room that 10
years ago said they would never get a
cell phone because their pager was good
enough we are living through major major
major communication shifts and it is
going to be exponential we live in a
mobile only world you just don't realize
it yet it's here it's happening and
whether Twitter becomes big and then not
big whether Facebook's here in five
years or not I don't care I don't care
Facebook snapchat Twitter Instagram
Tumblr Pinterest all disappeared that
concept of us consuming information and
making business decisions and living our
lives through this is here and then it
will be here and then I'll be here and
then we'll be [ __ ] robots but now but
for now but for now it is here and if
your entire business strategy is not
about where people's attention is when
you look at the data of finish use on
the Internet today and on cell phone
usage when you look at your customers in
this country not in America of the
percentage of time that everybody in
Finland spends on a social network in a
mobile device it is up to almost 50% of
all usage only gaming and utility apps
are anywhere close all of a sudden the
words
social media instead of some little
thing on the side a little sprinkle a
little nice to have when you think the
way I think which is this is the most
important device in the world and more
than half of our time all of us have our
time in this device is spent on a social
network it becomes a little bit more
important I mean literally guys tonight
when I go out and Helsinki I would
rather have somebody come up to me stab
me in the stomach with a knife and steal
my wallet then lose my phone this is it
how many people here in every 24 hour
window every 24 hour window are in arms
reach of their telephone raise your hand
what do you think is happening what do
you think is happening you think you're
like who can't wait to leave this
amazing conference the Nordic business
conference go home and go to their
mailbox and carefully go through their
direct mail I mean what are we spending
our money on how do you think you're
getting customers it is time listen you
could get away with this [ __ ] in
2009 and say it's not here you could you
could when I was here at a different
conference in 2012 you could say uh not
yet my friends it's 2017 the date is in
place you may not like it you may go out
to dinner with your partner and you may
see two people sitting at dinner and
both of them are on a phone right and
you may say oh look how sad that is
technology so sad you can do that you
may not like that this is happening by
the way real quick when I see a couple
at dinner and they're on the phone the
whole time I don't think that's sad I
think it's amazing let me explain why
that same couple 15 years ago they just
sat across from each other at dinner and
didn't say a [ __ ] word
let me let me say one thing here for you
and this is a very good thing for
everybody leave this conference with
technology is not changing us technology
is exposing who we actually are so all
my friends I have a seven four year old
daughter all my friends are like oh I
hate that my kids are on the iPad all
day but the second the kid cries when
we're over and having drinks they throw
the iPad at them like it's medicine
right so it's time for us all to not be
hypocrites it is time for all of us to
understand it's 2017 you may not like
this you may not like this I let you
know what I love I love how everybody
has decided writing a letter is so
amazing we decided in the world that if
you write a letter that's some amazing
achievement that you're the greatest
person of all time we have made the
pencil and paper on a pedestal
yet if we text each other that seems
like not communicating our kids are not
communicating it's the same [ __ ] it's
the same [ __ ] do you understand and the
longer you hold out and you want it to
be 2002 and 1997 and 1983 great knock
yourself out but let me make you a
promise
technology will run you over somebody
who's smaller than you will take your
business because the attention the
attention of all of our consumers and
all of age groups and all demos and all
countries in 2017 is here and when you
understand what people pay attention to
here it is Facebook it is YouTube
it is blogs it is LinkedIn it is Twitter
and you better figure out how you story
tell and how you mark it on these
platforms because if you don't you will
be finished thank you
[Music]
yes
[Music]
what an amazing it's my god what a
wake-up call that was thank you so much
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
is anybody else pissed off like I am
that is 2016 and that needs to be a
wake-up call unfortunately that is the
case that is the case and it feels damn
good to be awakened good in a common
sense and you know but I do will enjoy
going to southern France to pick up a
prize you know that that's uh it feels
good
we've got a huge amount of questions I
think the one that I want to use you
know you back please I'll give you this
perhaps if yes you change your clothes
you are somewhat what is what are you
wearing tell me that first please it's
where my favorite football players
Jersey altoon was a Kjetil that there
you go yes what college did he go to
don't know Wisconsin all right let's do
the question Gary thanks for being here
there is it my name is auntie Marilla
the Finch Finland is one of my companies
I do have a question because I'm a half
immigrant my wife she's a coach in
Boston so I spent half the time in
Boston half the time here and I would
say for me being in front of you all of
you wearing this strange clothing for
business conference is more natural than
for many people around here and by the
way you're on live on my facebook no
problem and my question is how can you
encourage these people finns who are a
bit different we're more shy to be here
and they trade their attention and like
for me saying that if you have an
e-commerce in Adwords I'm the guy to go
to if you spend more than 5k a month
how can people be stand-up do it I get
it I get it
look I think and I addressed it earlier
I listen every culture has its own game
right like I don't think that I have no
interest and I definitely don't have the
audacity or the hypocrisy to come here
and
be like me be crazy wear a jersey from a
different football team from a different
country
stand up disrupt the entire conference
you know he's a typical Finnish guy huh
what what what I love about that is
that's real for you on 10th right that's
real for you and you should do that and
for a lot of people here if you're
introverted for example the example I
spent most of my time on the talk today
it wasn't about being crazy on video
like I am that's what I'm comfortable
with some people are just great writers
maybe you use SoundCloud and you do
audio everybody here has to deploy one
very important thing self-awareness you
have to know who you are you you
shouldn't be crazy because there's not a
lot of crazy in Finland you shouldn't be
reserved or introverted because that's
what's accepted you need to be you and
you need to be you and you need to be
you and once you get comfortable with
being you it's unbelievable what starts
happening now whether it is through
written form audio video you need to
figure out the medium that allows you to
communicate to the world and in which
platforms here because you will be very
successful if you can figure that out by
not talking by not communicating in the
best form for you where people actually
are you are leaving money opportunity
raising money for charities whatever you
want to accomplish in your life you're
leaving that on a table so the punchline
is self-awareness man I'm not gonna tell
them go do this I don't know them I
don't know you do you you know you stop
being scared of who you are be yourself
yeah be yourself everybody else is taken
we know that one I think it's so fair we
have we have one question come out I'm
gonna take a digital question I'll get
back to you in a second this one you
know because you you did tell us that
you you were there before everybody was
on Yahoo you were on Google before
everybody else and that's I think it's a
good question for you is what's next on
social media where are we going you know
yeah where are we going wrong and where
we should we be I have no idea
thank you next question please
now I'll expand and and but I think it's
the truth I think the biggest mistake
people think and Seth gets it I'm sure
and Peter gets in all these great things
we're not futurist I'm not Nostradamus
right I don't know what's happening next
here's what I know I put in the work
when I see something pop for the last
eight weeks on the iTunes eyes store App
Store there's an app called Marco Polo
that has been in the top 150 so I
downloaded it and I made my team
download it and I watch people using it
and I use it I taste it and I'm not
crippled you know so many people here
think well that's a waste of time if it
doesn't become big I think it's a big
disadvantage for you not to do it in
case it becomes big so I play with
Socialcam and Plurk
and all these things that nobody talks
about but I equally played with Twitter
and Facebook and Tumblr and snapchat and
Instagram the key is I don't know what's
next but every time I see something that
is happening a little bit I put in the
work on vine when vine was popping two
years ago I stayed up from midnight to 2
o'clock in the morning because I was
very busy and I used it every night and
I watched everybody I I watch people
behave I have one thing I have one
Talent I know what you're gonna do
before you know you're gonna do it
that's a good talent and I do it by
intuition but also looking at the data
and also watching and then watching what
you do with it so to me I don't know
what's next I just know that the second
something pops a little bit unlike most
of you I'm not scared to put in the work
to figure it out yes great answer
we have another eager gentleman tell us
who you are please
hey Gary my name is aunty aunty since
the USC talk in 2015 you've been like my
digital uncle like you kind of answer
all my questions go why can't we be
brothers what do you say to mold you get
you're gonna be my digital big brother
yes all right go ahead I was thinking
like do I have a question for Gary
anymore because you've answered so many
questions but I figured out okay
our company is gonna explode if we
manage to scale our story okay and I'm
gonna need a lot of people for that and
let's put it this way and I'm gonna get
the money to scale from you or set for
someone else I think you should do it
because we're about time and about
attention okay but so my question is I
come to the States
yes and I want vaynermedia to do our
marketing there okay but you have 800
people so when I buy from vaynermedia I
want to buy what you know so how have
you managed to scale your culture so let
the person who is handling my account is
gonna be as good as you they're not so
it is cheaper than yes I'm very
expensive no so here's the punchline my
challenge wasn't to hire people listen
first of all anybody that's as good as
me would not work for me let's be very
smart about this my job is not to make
you be able to buy me my job is to make
sure that everybody in my company when
we have an account is better than
anything else you could buy that's the
game the game is not me
nobody buys me and I'm very upfront with
clients clients want to buy me and I
explain I'm the CEO of the company I run
the company I'm setting the vision I
need to be working on Marco Polo and
understand that when I decided video for
the phone was the most important thing
three years ago I was the one who hired
the first 20 people that would make
video for the phone those are the things
I have to do my game is not to do that
my game is to create a culture
internally of being better than the
alternative in the marketplace okay so
Florida culture how do
choose the right people one and how do
you make sure they're good enough when
they for example become a manager or so
I think the biggest mistake people make
here that are running businesses is they
are spending too much time on hiring and
not enough strategy on firing so I mean
this and I know it's a funny thing to
say I think I have unbelievable
emotional intelligence it's my intuition
I have great people skills it's the
thing I probably pride my see you know
this it's the thing I pride myself the
most on I am stunned how many times I've
been wrong hiring it's hard it's hard so
what I do now is I actually don't spend
any time on hiring when I built
vaynermedia this time from 30 to 200
people we made happen in a year
I hired everybody I mean you could walk
in and like say I don't have a computer
I'm like hired you know I hired
everybody because when you're scaling I
need to taste it it's much like the apps
I don't know what's next but I'll try it
and then I'll know you don't know what
you have in an employee what you have to
do is be upfront hey John you have to
understand I'm hiring quickly I don't
know if you're gonna be good
but in three or four months if I don't
think you're good we're probably gonna
let you go and I want to be upfront with
you because you may not want on your
resume that you only work here for three
months so you're taking a risk here too
you have to be up front you have to be a
stand-up but that's my strategy how do I
know we hire we now we're at scale we
know better what to look for but we're
not always right but the key is to make
sure people can't stay in the system if
they're not qualified first emotionally
if you are not good with the other boys
and girls you are fired even if you're
the best
second meritocracy you have to be good
enough to carry your weight because
we're not running a non-profit
either got it so that's how thank you
very much Anna this is the last question
the biggest one can I take you to dinner
tonight we're talking about advantages
yes conference and you know fiddlin has
a many advantages that you probably have
already already you know seen but we
have some disadvantage when it comes to
wine you know the weather is not very
good for wine
but we do have great spirit okay or
great spirits and would you would you
accept would you accept you to taste one
of Finland's most famous spirit for us
would you said that yes right now all
right all right
a dope Cup would you come here please
this is a bit of a taste test for you
Gary come on over here
it's like this and this is a very
special a oka is gonna pour you
something called Motzkin rube - thank
you how are you and there are two
questions related to this it has to be a
filled to the rim is the tradition yes
this is our I think I talked to you
about this
it's a Marshall Marshall minor ham a
great war hero a president of the
Republic had but one of his staff
invents this drink I want I I want you
to tell us what you think but also it
has three spirits in it what are they
I'm only pounding this because I love
all of you all right here we go
lehayim time you have become an honorary
Finn what did you think of that what did
you think of that
your commentary please I think I have
more hair on my chest
not bad not bad actually
licorice um a little bit of almost do
you know what pine tar is mm-hmm
it's a little pine tar eucalyptus okay
okay okay and what's in it yes what do
you think you know I'm a very famous but
big you know actually mainstream ladders
that I've been this it's it's to me it's
got vodka sambuca yeah I mean vodka
stands out for me yeah um one good one
maybe a little hint of gin yes I hate
the gin a bit vodka or what we call Vina
in this country okay Vern mooch vermouth
got it give him a big hat for trying
that yeah
how about taking them you know a
question from these guys on this side
anybody want to ask a question to Gary
Vee askgaryvee hashtag Gary Vee answer
this while somebody's coming up we have
somebody over there we have somebody
who's uh could you come up here and
catch this box for us I'm gonna answer
this for the ratings how do you
prioritize your total and that's my next
one for you okay you want cheese you're
very rigid I'm rigid man but for
somebody with orange is very rigid not
for you okay he has one there he's good
we'll take that if that's okay thank you
good you're on man go for it yeah tell
us who you are in your question please
whines how are you I'm good thanks yeah
the question is we want to know if we've
taken on board of your ideas and they're
working really well once we see that one
more time
you've taken I talk really fast sorry we
were taking on your ideas we dark post
etc it's working really well Bob one
more time I didn't hear it I didn't hear
it and they're working really well dark
posts etc they quit next question is yes
how can we convert snapchat and
Pinterest into sales
so snapchat especially right now is much
more like television and outdoor media
it's not dr it's not last touch
attribution you're not gonna see the
sale though ironically because I'm very
close to this snapchat infrastructure
I'm an investor we're an API partner
there's a lot of dr coming we ran a
campaign recently for a tee where you
swipe up from the creative and convert
the form inside I think snapchat two
three four years from now will be a real
dr play a conversion sales play but you
have to understand it and this is
actually thank you so much for this
question I'm glad I got to say this
because I've been wanting to talk about
it more my friends there's a very big
difference between sales and marketing
and we're blending them too much right
now what I'm doing I'm doing marketing
I'm creating awareness I'm giving you my
Diaz you may go down the rabbit hole may
follow me you're getting into my funnel
you become aware of Who I am that's
marketing it's not
I'm not gonna end this talk with like
and now go to my website and buy my book
that's not what you do so I think when
you think about snapchat think about is
marketing right listen you know my
schpeel I'm not looking for your money I
haven't asked you for any money I'm
building brand all my content is free
you're not going down a funnel that then
charges you $100 a month so you need to
do some of that Facebook is incredible
for marketing and sales right
Twitter's remark over that Pinterest is
very easy for sales all those images
link out Pinterest ads work quite well
the problem for Pinterest that I'm an
investor in that company and I'm
disappointed they have not moved to
mobile as well as they could have they
want on desktop but they've struggled
with the mobile transition and I see the
head nod so I think one thing you need
and your young dude one thing that you
need to really understand is there's
platforms that are great for sales
there's platforms that's great for
marketing but to be really big you have
to do both and some platforms Facebook
are incredible at both which is why
they're special ok thanks a lot you got
a brother I identified this question
because you says so much about your hard
work your discipline and what it takes
to really achieve what you've achieved
has a lot to do with your regimen with
yeah I mean I I didn't cover it real
quick I didn't cover it and so many of
you raised your hand you know you know
you didn't know who I was and I should
probably drank more of that in the
beginning when I saw that um I you know
one thing I would say and this is an
American thing I do believe that but I
just believe in hard work you know no
matter how talented you are I love when
people say Gary you always talk about a
lot of work but I work smart I go Rick I
work smart and hard now what [ __ ] so
so you're right I'm a very big believer
that if you were sitting in this room
and you're trying to achieve great
things it's very hard to do that in a 5
7 8 hour work day
it just is somebody's gonna work 9 10
and 11 and that's very competitive but
family interests everybody should live
their lives the way they want to but if
you want to build something big if you
want to create a big business hard work
is the first second and third part of
the formula thank you so much for that
I can't you can't emphasize that enough
how about up there we've had a lot of
questions from the front rows how about
back there to section one anybody with
an insightful question for Gary before
he leaves us he has exactly four minutes
33 seconds left while I've got the time
while Sir he's deciding raise your hand
if you want to do this but I'll say
something - just bring Valley during the
downtime another thing that I want to
make sure and I see there's a lot of
executives in this room everything
you've just heard please make sure that
you don't do that a question
yeah come up make sure you don't do what
everybody does which is if you're a
senior executive review on your own
business and you heard this talk and say
oh wait I think he's right don't go and
just hire a 23 year old and assume that
they understand this that 23 year old
was using their mobile device in social
media to hook up with people not
necessarily to sell stuff and more
importantly and by the way there's some
23 year olds that know how to sell stuff
but let's not do the cliche thing and
say oh yes my niece she's on Instagram
she's gonna help my business that is not
smart everybody does that please don't
do that and number two how many people
here own their business raise your hand
a lot so listen a lot one more time hi I
just wanted okay here's the most
important part and I'm really glad I got
to say this everything I just talked
about so many of you gonna say I don't
understand this I didn't grow up with
this I don't know this if you own your
own business don't you think it makes
sense for you to take 20 hours to either
read or watch videos on how to place
facebook ads how to place Instagram ads
how does LinkedIn work
what is medium calm when you have the
audacity to be an entrepreneur and own
your own business and want all the
riches and great things that come with
it you need to put in the work I promise
you if you look at your eight hours
every day two to three of them you're
spending on dumb [ __ ] you're spending it
like it's 1994 take that back
go to YouTube and Google search how to
place Facebook Ads
how does
snapchat work does Instagram work for
b2b SAS whatever it may be spend 40 50
60 hours do because the biggest thing
I'm concerned about one more time show
of hands business owners the biggest
concern I have is that you're gonna hide
or somebody and you have no idea what
they're doing how are you gonna judge if
that person is doing something by the
way if you don't understand this
you're gonna lose either way either
you're gonna hire somebody who's not
gonna do [ __ ] for you but knows how to
trick you into thinking that they are or
they're gonna do well it's gonna matter
to your business and then she or he will
have the leverage and either leave and
do their own thing or it will require a
lot more money from you you have to be
the best person in your organization of
the work when I stand in front of a new
media it's 800 people very young sharp
best-in-class and when I stand in front
of them say I'm the best at social media
me the old guy the [ __ ] uncle right
I'm I'm the guys were finished here that
you identified that's right and so to me
and to me you have to be the best
executor in your organization where this
is communication and communication
drives everything we're going to get up
one last question from you please thank
you I'm sure so well you answered my
question already well it was great to
see you
okay question for you Gary
is that really it before our next
speaker what go ahead
okay so well you know I was a bit
confused with snapchat okay
and I thought myself I got old yes and I
also confirm with my friends who
graduated with me yes they all got old
yeah you're old yeah so but you know I'm
still trying
I'm sure to understand what snapchat it
how can it bring the value and do
because you have to understand this is
perfect I got 38 seconds nine years ago
Facebook was for college now it is not
how does it bring value if snapchat
holds on which I think it will in five
years my friend you won't be as old as
you think
you're gonna want to do business and
snapchat is gonna have 30 to 50 year old
fin consumers in its platform you need
to figure out how to make content in
there that makes them want to do
business with you well trust me I'm
spending half an hour every day from
last two months I love it man
good hustle work thank you
[Music]
founder Chuck hazing God what energy
look at this guy
yes I love
thank you thank you Gary
thank you
yes cool now comments-section give me
your favorite thing that's happened so
far on this Thanksgiving weekend in the
US and everybody outside the US what is
your plans for the weekend
you